our intrepid heroes that made light work
oh the threat to our no book about these
illusions 16 mighty assurance in this
level where whisper really showcases how
truly useless she really is I see the
one on the right ahead actually I was
damaged
Leo me
why don't we do it Oh God
fall into moving around I'm just going
to achieve it wrong
located
when video games like reference memes
like that it's just
come on get with times like in results
when you have two things it is like
update them to have me it just made me
sad it's like really dumb some of them
are just for the most part it just feels
really cheesy
muddy muddy for Thank You person who
threw 50 gold coins me a total of seven
thousand six hundred gold they'll be in
the head no man subsided like that in
peg 10,000 now that's if he doesn't even
seem that good why are they are getting
very tough for our contestants we can
all see that they're feeling astray
thank you guys really go go hero they're
winning I love no it's a rock crawl okay
more Travis Rock trolls I think the
other ones must be crowned troll step 3
I know there's our straw girls too
plan
sure
Doug then probably could just run away
from me it's not that fast
see she's doing like no damn it
how did you even get here who invited
you I had to get like accepted or
denominated nominated look I don't want
to be funny maybe to prank maybe it was
the more and his offices like the fire
don't remember who actually did it thank
you yeah that's totally the same
let us enter is a highly photo/john
because every month Russian Dumbledore's
are like yet yes but gets away with it
oh you don't dead my door anybody help
it's like when my car
I'm confused but still pleased the exact
same kind of thing right because I'm
just getting more XP from this dude
do
oh she's done so
yes kick at the giant
battle battle rock even though I know
for a fact that you also have magic
maybe
this one lady in the audience just keeps
a motion to Jason I don't know who she
is but have a good feeling about this
my place afterwards because I actually
do own a bunch of houses all over that
real estate that's actually something
that I really like about fable 2 which I
guess it was really cool though being
I'm like
kind of manipulate the mom if you can do
it in this game as well when it's a lot
hottest trade is tend to be the one who
have good deals on them you just sort of
find them at random times or is it able
to be like my thing at one store go to
other school in hora area
so maybe maybe that shouldn't be a thing
that I should like maybe
it's too simple editor I still enjoyed
doing it that way once again you have no
house
alright
Wow another eight thousand file hey yes
awesome next is only one round to go is
it worth dying for another yeah another
10,000 the 41 money perhaps
no suddenly nighttime that's quick
family I don't have real son sex ravine
what for just BAM night I caught you out
of nowhere I'm kind of fun I guess give
you if not times just spontaneous you
didn't know what it was and it just
suddenly drops by like 10 degrees all
right I'm ready ass
oh that's right this thing no yeah no I
wasn't wearing for that I thought this
was the pot way don't fight this yet
okay
like I should just I know there are no
expressions I want to use
that will do that hey buddy hey buddy
right
miss you scooch where the little things
are totally spawns little things maybe
don't
rolls into the ground ha ha I can kill
them like this
can I totally can die hahahaha okay it's
gonna take a long time and they often
bowling out the map what uh leaders
coming up back in it's not a problem
we'll get the head will get their eyes
come on okay we're not gonna get there
nobody
screaming do the thing
yes
see i'm pretty sure that what that does
is make a thing and attack
anything really which could just be
because I'm super ultimate this
it could also be something i don't know
i'm not a scientist i'm pretty sure
that's yes
buddy back yeah I do that thing i like
when you do that and spawn body parts
through the ground which totally makes
sense
that's what are you not entertained I
think that's wrong
the arena is broken there's one mouth
gasps I'm a little thing left here this
is for a massive total a thousand six
winner incredible so I'm excited class
good winner I don't sleep frog is one of
my favorite characters that's okay we
have a special guest here today I have
returned after an eternity away from you
all jack of blades yeah they didn't use
the original voice there's two different
voices this arena is all that is great
inhale Mia
and you it is worthy and one of them
just makes him sound like a weird
British time honored to stand before you
again and I have a proposal to mark the
occasion one final round a fight to the
death between the two heroes still stand
the winner will receive a stanza dreamy
the loser will have the privilege of
dying you telling people what did I
think they're doing yeah no two voices
in the other one is way cooler that one
sounds to one's gonna love it face how's
the line you can do in a good show and
that's what we lines aside next girl
okay all right let's do this hey girl
yeah I know
resilient to the iron
you doing not really dark don't touch
things that's not a good time nobody
wants that
like how I can multitask like the balls
collect the money that my
and like
come
even storms
obviously oh cool you know what you know
what you should do when you're fighting
a common its flipped over the top of
them and then land with your back facing
room who told you that genius cuz i
receive Duncan
we have to do is give her one final
strike so I don't care about bonus prize
I tend to play rpgs but I'm by doing
whatever it is that I would actually do
in that situation we just walk out um
yeah no I think I think then I'm not
gonna kill her because she's like the
only person I have from my childhood as
much she didn't quite make a huge [ __ ]
my whole life though um see i'll play
another playthrough any way when I go is
good and another one where I goes my bad
don't care about the reward
leave just me I don't know what to do
she's been a [ __ ] okay no I'm gonna go
mostly it's okay to give the [ __ ]
Ilana you'll get through this don't
deserve to die that just [ __ ] right
sounds about right really long loading
screen with a dancing troll of some kind
but my dear lady it was mere luck he's
nothing but what a lady grey there you
are the hero they're all talking about
I'm impressed I hang in that basket when
women talk like that in games like
everything they say sections I sighs
weirdo the man how many drugs do you on
about fitting see you are a man of worth
you should pay me a visit at my
bowerstone North manner my lady if you
would only sander I am tired of your
protests tired of your jealousy the time
of your glory is long gone nystrom
should learn to accept that as I was
saying here oh I do hope you will accept
my invitation do we have much to discuss
is it you naked oh yeah it kind of is
IAM pretty sure you can bang her this is
not over your blood spills just like any
no it doesn't make yours like your blood
spills but but i have a shield spelled
on thunder I have a shield spell so by
definition that doesn't happen you don't
even understand that is it from me today
everyone I'm Alana or char Alana's odd
and thank you guys for watching this
quick little let's play I'm thinking
about doing like more Let's Plays of my
favorite parts of some of my favorite
games because I just don't have the time
to do entire games and it's a good
excuse for me to go back and play some
of the stuff I love so I suppose that
isn't for fable anniversary at one of my
favorite games and that was the arena
thank you for watching I'll see you guys
next time